to keep the orangutan program working
there are 130 staff people employed in
Borneo rehabilitating over 300 orphans
requires a great deal of work and
dedication you have caregivers who take
care of the array motels when they are
the small what they do is they take the
around the chance into the forest every
day and a lot clearer and tons teach
each other did you take care of
orangutans it can't be yes I have little
baby named Thomas I taken care of him
for two years if you didn't see me and
I'm talking he will cry because he knows
my voice you can really where is my mum
the youngest paprika with the let
assistant Antonia five years after five
years they go to many assistants because
they climb trees higher and they call
father well I pretty much grew up with
Ryan ten zacapa leekie
my best friend actually starting in
brown five years old was an orangutan
named Apollo Bob we used to climb trees
go in the river as daily activities to
keep us entertained in a camp where
there were no toys around the other
remarkable group of animal workers from
born to be wild are the elephant keepers
in Kenya despite my fast feeling of
loving all animals now I love elephants
more than I loved in Iran this is a
buggy
he takes seen a lot it consumes about
almost 18 points after every three hours
we have got along at 30 keep us and we
keep on rotating this is just to avoid
them from peeing attached to one keeper
since the night went so much once the
milky just won't just wake me up with a
child it just get a strong Kia through
their gender ah then
then they wake up the most important
quality for keepers he's got to
genuinely love the elephants they can
read your heart you know even visitors
have come that really really love them
they respond to that they're just
amazing in that way I really enjoy what
I do I take care of them as I take care
of my own babies to them and their
mother they are very wonderful creatures
very intelligent and I love them